merci beaucoup
lorsque j'ai été invité à cette
manifestation on m'a dit il est question
d'avoir du fun du plaisir donc comme on
ne sait jamais je me suis amené mon
propre jouer au moins les choses sont
les shows sont posées se peut-il se
peut-il donc d'abord je vais honorer ce
qui est présent ce qui est présente très
sincèrement c'est une petite envie de
silence c'est je vais parler de
congruence et d'alignement ce qui est
présent pour moi maintenant tout de
suite tout de suite c'est une petite
envie de silence et si vous voulez bien
m'accompagner dans ça j'aimerais que
pendant 30 secondes 45 secondes vous
alliez à la rencontre de ce qui
s'opèrent profondément profondément s'il
vous plaît en vous l'exercice est
difficile parce que c'est court quand
vous faites l'expérience d'un silence
absolu à l'intérieur de vous même vous
êtes prêts on y va pour 30 45 secondes
silence absolu et qu'est-ce qui résonne
en vous vous le gardez pour vous et
c'est une expérience pour vous intime
c'est parti
voilà ce petit moment là ce petit cette
petite rencontre vers qui vous êtes
fondamentalement vraiment je pense que
c'est l'une des choses qui nous manque
le plus cette expérience fondamentale du
silence revenons à la créativité
se peut-il que créativité soit
directement fondamentalement corrélé à
liberté mieux que ça au sentiment de
liberté
hypothèse nous sommes tous je veux
croire en tout cas que nous sommes tous
fabriqués d'une espèce dax je vais le
définir comme étant granitique une
espèce dax verticale j'ai été moi s'il
vous plaît parce que sinon je vais en
avoir plein les mains fait des mois s'il
vous plaît je peux vous en donner deux
trois merci merci beaucoup
une espèce dax verticale granitique
pourtant intangible mais qui serait le
compte de ce que nous sommes vraiment
cet axe fondamental de qui nous sommes
et petit déjà j'avais cette sensibilité
aux énergies avec les arbres et je l'est
toujours aujourd'hui évidemment mais
elle s'est déployée
je dirais par ailleurs et l'impression
que j'ai pour ce qui me concerne c'est
que finalement je suis fabriqué d'un
certain nombre de sphères d'électrons
peut-être d'énergie de disques mais en
tout cas de couronnes qui me constitue
et qui me permettent finalement d'entrer
en relation par l'énergie avec les
différents mondes dans lesquels je
gravite et très simplement
on pourrait imaginer y en a une
foultitude évidemment mais on pourrait
imaginer que l'un de ces cercles par
exemple c'est celui qui me met en
relation avec la connaissance et il y as
entre mon axe central verticale
intangible mais pourtant si présent si
fort il y a une connexion très
particulière qui s'opère entre cette
énergie qui circule et finalement la
connaissance
il est aussi un comment dirais-je une
strate d'une partie de deux petits je
suis d' qui nous sommes peut-être
qui va être le socle de de ma capacité à
relatiosn et avec la sphère
professionnelle avec le monde de
l'entreprise par exemple
et puis une autre qui va être finalement
une sphère de d'énergie grâce à laquelle
je vais interagir et communiquer avec
finalement ma famille personnelle ma
famille personnelle j'entends celle que
j'ai fabriqué moi même non pas celle
dont je viens mais voilà et donc qu'il
ya comme ça pour mon sentiment
tiens une pièce on dit que ça porte
bonheur aux usa faut ramasser les pièces
il dit
je la rendrai à l'organisation premier
toujours est il que le sentiment que
j'ai c'est que ces différentes strates
me permettent d'interagir avec les
différentes je dirais partie de
l'existence où ma vie où la vie se
déploie et ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
on regarde de l'expérience passée c'est
finalement le constat que lorsque pour
certaines parties de mon existence parce
que pour certains champs de ces
relations qui me met au contact du monde
ou des mondes et bien le constat c'est
que finalement plus se faire d'énergie
sont éloignés de mon axe central et plus
le processus de désensibilisation
s'opère et plus finalement il ya de la
souffrance et donc l'invitation quelque
part que je me suis formulée à moi même
c'est d'aller essayer de récupérer
finalement ces différentes parties de
moi qui se sont trouvés finalement
éloigné de ce que je suis vraiment parce
que finalement tout concourt à nous
éloigner de qui nous sommes
l'absence de contact direct avec la
nature par exemple le temps s'y limiter
le temps s'y limiter pendant lequel nous
passons nous vivons sans rien au dessus
de nos têtes
sans rien au-dessus notait nous passons
de virer quelque chose au dessus de nos
têtes
le temps du contact véritable avec la
nature l'expérience du silence toutes
ces choses là et finalement ce monde un
petit peu
extrêmement mondial juif concours a
concouru pour moi à m'éloigner un petit
peu plus les chefs du passé de qui
j'étais fondamentalement donc
l'invitation serait peut-être celle ci
de travailler à l'agglomération
finalement de qui nous sommes et ça va
parler à manuel a donc écouté avec grand
intérêt tout à l'heure et est finalement
une fois que ces pièces sont rassemblés
vous pouvez me rendre ces parties de moi
qui étais un peu lointaine snobisme
merci beaucoup
petit à petit et c'est un chemin eh bien
merci beaucoup et bien les choses se
rassemblent et l'image qui me venaient
et que j'ai pu exprimer par ailleurs
c'est finalement comme si nous étions
fait de deux rails un premier rail qui
va être comment dirais-je le qui je suis
et un second rail qui va être la façon
qu aura le monde de nous percevoir et
est le résultat de cet éparpillement de
cette fragmentation de ce détricotage
peut-être parfois c'est que finalement
plus cette distance est grande et plus
et plus il ya de tensions plus il ya des
sensibilisations et peut-être peut-être
plus il ya de souffrance cet enjeu là
cet enjeu la de cet alignement de 7-2-2
d'honorer ce qui est présent au plus
profond de nous mêmes de ce contact avec
qui nous sommes vraiment il est
fondamental parce que pour ce qui me
concerne et il m'a permis de me sentir
libre et quand je parle de liberté de
sentiment de liberté plus que de liberté
alors alors je deviens disponibles au
monde alors je peux entrer en relation
avec l'autre
alors je peux l'accueillir dans la
diversité non plus être nick ce sont des
schémas du passé bientôt vous verrez on
parlera de la diversité des formes
d'intelligence alors on basculera
finalement en quelque sorte une fois
bien alignées dans un monde où savoir
être savoir faire savoir avoir vont se
transformer en quelque chose de
fantastique qui sera au potentiel énorme
qui sera le savoir-être avec l'autre
le savoir-faire avec l'autre et le
savoir à voir avec l'autre
ce potentiel là est déployée alors on
rentre dans quelque chose d'absolument
fantastique sans limite de co création
et de fondations de quelque chose sans
aucun doute de quelque chose de plus
grand que nous mêmes je vous remercie